you're being sued by the SEC correct
clients are withdrawing from your funds
not claims in certain clients and their
individual clients in some cases setting
in more money well that's encouraging
for you certainly most money managers
would be in hiding right now why not you
well you know I would say and I don't
want to praise myself anyway everyone
has to act according to their own set of
values I'd say if this happens with 30
year old with no money you rat a
business it happened to happen to a
thirty seventy three-year-old that's
reasonably financially well-off I value
my legacy I've done nothing wrong and I
take comfort from that fact and a guy
that is like one of my heroes I'm sure
you know him ken Langone called me up
four months ago when this all hit and he
said something that I totally totally
resonated with me he said Lee I've known
you for 40 years I've been invested with
you for over 10 years I know what you
stand for I can only advise you and tell
you that the best thirty million dollars
I ever spent that's Ken Langone spending
it was my thirty million dollars of fame
myself against Eliot Spitzer don't give
them a dime if you've done nothing wrong
and I remember from my past when I was a
good diligent student Robert Harper in
1798 coined the phrase millions for
defense not one cent for tribute and so
this is costing me substantially more
than they wanted me to give them by
legal fees I take it or the legal fee
and lost business legal fees in lost
business are astronomical and it really
makes me sad because I give you a
commercial you know I've taken a Giving
Pledge with Warren Buffett I believe
that I am my brother's keeper I want to
give my money back to society and with
the my children my grandchildren my wife
we have something called the Koopman
college Scholars who would basically
have a program to send 500 kids in Essex
County New Jersey to college what this
is gonna cost me I could probably
multiply the five hundred by five fold
it's a shame because it's life-changing
for the kids giving them something to
look forward to but it is what it is you
know there's nothing but you could do
lay people who don't know you the way
ken Langone
knows you and other friends of yours and
investors know you will ask this
question do you as a matter of practice
in an effort to produce returns for your
investors sail close to the wind do you
bump on anything at all against the
limits of the law not even close we are
a deep dive fundamental firm information
is not a crime we speak with companies
who tried to develop information Iran
goldman sachs research for 14 years we
were deferring for 25 years we always
told the analysts if a company gives you
something that significant non-public
information basically urged the company
to make a press release we're not
looking for inside information we're
looking for insight don't make any
attempt to outlaw speaking with
companies we are on a level playing
field we do not seek inside information
I would love to go into the facts around
this case but my lawyers got me muzzled
but it is so sad what's going on I can't
begin to tell you